Okay. In this short video, I wanna show
you where we are with Shopify.
Shopify is an OAuth two credential
manager
for Kubernetes.
So the first thing we're gonna do is
apply an OAuth API
spec.
What does that look like? Well, we can
take a look at our discord. Yaml here.
The first thing we define is our OAuth
API. Here I'm defining one for Discord.
Now it has a few HTTP based settings,
such as the base URL,
the authorization
header prefix,
and then some headers that are expected to
go along with the request.
We also can configure the authorization method.
Here, we set the authorization URL and the
token URL.
Discord also requires that we specify the response
type and the grant type. So those are
specified under the authorization prompt.
Next, we can define,
try not to reveal anything secret here,
the OAuth connection.
The OAuth connection has a name of Discord
and we tell it which API this connection
is for. This means you can have multiple
OAuth connections for the Discord API with different
users or scopes if required.
Next, we define the scopes that we want,
and then we specify where the credentials,
the client ID and the client secret
for this API live.
Here, we're using a secret ref to OAuth
connection
Discord,
and we specify the keys used for the
client ID and the client secret.
And I have these specified in this file,
but I'm not going to show you that.
We can apply our examples Discord
like so.
From here, we can run get auth
APIs and we'll see that we have our
Discord API.
If we describe it,
we'll just see that it is registered
and there's not really too much to do
with this.
However,
I also have my OAuth
connection.
And if we describe this
OAuth connections,
Then we'll see that we have our OAuth
connection now. It started initializing.
It detected that we actually have the client
ID and secret available.
So we're currently in the disconnected state.
This is OAuth, so we have to do
the OAuth dance. No ifs, no buts.
So if we jump over to the web
interface for Shopify
and hit refresh,
you'll see that we now have a disconnected
Discord API.
We can click connect,
does a dance,
and now our API is connected.
There we go.
Our phase is set to connected,
which is good. And if we run get
secrets, we'll see that we have the shop
AI Discord secret.
Of course, I'm not gonna show you this
secret because that will give away my OAuth
token.
But now, the secret is under management of
shop I.
Whenever our OAuth token is about to expire,
Shopify will request a refresh from Discord.
Happy OAuth.